pues bueno ha llegado la hora de
resolver una integral indefinida pero
esta integración definida la vamos a
tomar como la integral de 3x cuadrada
más 2x y esto va a multiplicar el
elevado a la x cúbica más x cuadrada y
todo esto multiplicado por de x y bueno
la primera vez que tú ves este tipo
integrales tú dices yo no tengo un
polinomio de x que a su vez está
multiplicando a la función exponencial
que a su vez está elevada a otro
polinomio de x como se resuelve en este
tipo de integrales sin embargo en esta
ocasión vamos a tomar una nueva forma de
integración que se llama la sustitución
o la sustitución 1 o el cambio de
variable es decir lo que vamos a hacer
es renombrar a una nueva variable y tú
me vas a decir qué es esto cómo vamos a
hacer un cambio de variable pero fíjate
la idea es pensar justo lo contrario a
la regla de la cadena me voy a fijar
primero en qué función tiene el
exponente que en este caso es la función
exponencial si nosotros pensamos un poco
en el exponente de la función
exponencial nos va
a dar cuenta que es x pública x cuadrado
es este que tenemos aquí y para darle
mayor énfasis lo voy a cuadricular para
que lo tomen en cuenta y bueno qué va a
pasar si derivamos este exponente que
depende de x es decir calculamos la
derivada con respecto a x bueno
curiosamente es 3x cuadrada más 2 x es
decir es este polinomio que está
multiplicando a la función exponencial y
como es la derivada del exponente es
justo cuando se nos ocurre pensar en la
sustitución o o en el cambio de variable
entonces voy a hacer el siguiente cambio
de variable
voy a decir que uno es igual a equis
cúbica más x cuadrada ojo estoy poniendo
la letra porque por convención se pone
la letra u pero puede ser cualquier
letra que se les ocurra y bueno
calculemos la derivada de eeuu con
respecto a x pues es la derivada de x
cúbica más x cuadrada que es 3x cuadrada
más 2x esta derivada ya las habíamos
calcular fácilmente ahora lo que voy a
pensar es que la derivada de eu con
respecto a x pues realmente es un cambio
muy pequeño es tan pequeño que podríamos
decir que
esto de aquí es un quebrado o dicho de
otra manera esto es una fracción y si
suponemos que esto es una fracción por
lo tanto yo puedo escribir esto de la
siguiente manera puedo multiplicar de
ambos lados por de x y yo voy a obtener
de x que multiplica de hubo entre de x
es igual a 3 x cuadrada más 2x que
multiplica de x pero de x que multiplica
y de x que dividen si consideramos que
son como quebrados se cancelan y por lo
tanto tendría que de v es igual a 3 x
cuadrada más 2 x de x esto se le conoce
como la forma diferencial de esta
derivada la diferencia del de 1 es igual
a 3 veces x cuadrada más 2x diferencial
de x y se dan cuenta es este y este que
tengo yo aquí ahora lo siguiente que voy
a hacer es escribir esta integral pero
acomodando los términos para que se vea
mucho más claro tienes de eeuu y quien
es uno entonces tengo la integral de 3x
cuadrada más 2 x 3 x cuadrada más 2 x
que multiplica a de x ojo estoy pasando
el de x primero porque el orden de los
factores no afecta el producto
a su vez multiplican al exponencial
elevada a la x cúbica más x cuadrada y
esto lo estoy haciendo para ordenarlo y
que se vea claramente que aquí todo esto
que tenemos es la diferencia del de eeuu
mientras que el polinomio que se
encuentra en el exponente es uno lo
habíamos bautizado con el nombre de uno
por lo tanto esto es un y estos de uno y
ahora lo que voy a hacer es escribir
esta integral pero haciendo el cambio de
variable o dicho de otra manera voy a
escribir esta integral en términos de la
nueva variable y lo primero que tenemos
es que todo esto que tenemos aquí es
decir dv lo voy a poner hasta el final
por convención porque así se escriben
las integrales entonces por notación
hasta atrás va de eeuu y después tengo
de un que multiplica al exponencial
elevado al x pública más x cuadrada pero
esto lo habíamos llamado como entonces
tenemos la integral de ea la diferencial
de 1 y esta es una integral muy sencilla
es una integral que ya sabemos resolver
recuerden que podemos ver las integrales
como anti derivadas
es decir en este caso cuál es la función
cuya derivada es
y bueno estudiado teníamos una fórmula
que decía que la integral de eeuu este
domingo que elevado a la más una
constante de integración nunca hay que
olvidar la constante de integración y
recuerden que esto es cierto porque
derivamos a la 'u' su derivada es ella
misma es decir
por lo tanto ya tenemos anti derivada
ahora esto está escrito en términos de
un cuando trabajemos la sustitución lo
que hay que hacer es la sustitución
hacia atrás es decir escribir
en términos de x o de la variable
original esto es porque mi integral
original está escrita en términos de x
por lo tanto hay que regresarnos a
términos de x y ya tenemos el resultado
era la x cúbica más x cuadrada más cm es
la solución de esta integral